so spannende frage wo dürfen wir diesen
sommer urlaub machen bis neulich dachte
ich und wenn es mir bill gates erlaubt
mit ganz viel glück im harz jetzt ist
plötzlich doch schon wieder von mallorca
die rede
ja die tourismusbranche macht
offensichtlich druck verständlicherweise
und länder wie griechenland wollen eines
tages auch mal wieder geld verdienen
aber ist das alles realistisch wer jetzt
nach spanien reist muss zum beispiel
erst mal 14 tage in quarantäne
sagen wir mal so dieser sommer wird
anders und dietmar wischmeyer ist
menschlich enttäuscht dietmar wischmeyer
the places airbus zur urlaub.de inkl
kreuzfahrtschiffe voll infizierter
dümpeln vor cuxhaven auf reede rund ums
mittelmeer bricht der verkauf der bild
zeitung zusammen beginnt so dass welten
ende dürfen wir nie wieder raus aus
deutschland hat uns heiko maas in diesem
jahr für immer heim ins reich geholt
urlaub in deutschland hilfe seit acht
wochen fahren wir schon mit dem rad
zwischen borkenkäfern und windrädern rom
vor lauter langeweile es reicht wir
können keine e bikes fitness bikes und
überhaupt irgendwelche scheiß bikes mehr
sehen wir wollen unser altes leben
zurück mit richtigem urlaub
billigflieger ballermann und bratwurst
buffet wir wollen nicht mit dem
herbergsvater durch die staubige
uckermark wandern oder mit millionen
anderen zwangsurlaub inzwischen
stinkigen wattwürmern verwesen wir
wollen auch im urlaub nicht abnehmen
nach dem deutschen wellness hotel und
uns dort von osteuropäischen leicht nun
kräften die pickel am arsch ausdrücken
lassen
wir wollen mit einem randvollen teller
vom buffet eine arschbombe bis warmen
pool machen das wollen wir alle laut
horst bitte gebt uns unseren schönen
urlaub zurück wir möchten einfach nur am
strand zwischen anderen fetten deutschen
kegelrobben rumliegen und denen die
sandburgen um kurzen zwei wochen einfach
mal nur in unterhose und heavy metal t
shirt durch fremde städte laufen und die
erste strophe von deutschland die
trübsten so war das und das war schön
hier haben die gäste natürlich wenig
verständnis für die probleme von einheit
weil es noch einmal mehr wenn die sich
gestört sind warum ziehen die hängen
sehr ehrlichen sie sollen informieren
haben ist mir egal was wird man auch in
el arenal geboren selber schuld und es
ist nicht ein deutsches menschenrecht
auch mal zwischendurch die seele baumeln
zu lassen
sensationell wir sind hier nur für
aktionen und schlinge wir zurück nur
jung gesellschaft party machen bisher
hierher party machen und dann mal wieder
zurück dass werden diese freudiges
kinder nie begreifen wie sensationell
geil das ist das soll jetzt alles vorbei
sein
warum warum reißt ihr die grenze nicht
alle sofort wieder auf grenzschutz ist
menschen schutz sagt der innenminister
des saarlands jeder abgewiesene franzose
bedeute ein stück mehr sicherheit für
die saarländer bass deshalb dürfen wir
nicht sofort wieder weg damit die
franzosen das sei deutlich überfallen
ich weiß doch was auch saarland so groß
wie mallorca war dreimal so tot so ich
hau ab und bucht er in den flug nach
malle bei ryanair gibt es gerade den
mittelsitz für neun euro
tschüssi copski allerseits dietmar
wischmeyer sagt leise servus zum urlaub
wie wir ihn kannten
nein ich mache hier gar nichts mehr
bevor ihr nicht den kanal abonniert und
nike da lass ich hab die schnauze voll
los lasst ein abo da